The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: OK, let us start.
So last time, we
finished discussing
quantization of closed
strings and open strings.
And we see-- we saw that if
you want to quantize strings
consistently in
Minkowski spacetime,
then you need 26 dimensions.
We also saw that when you
quantize the photon-- when
you quantize open
strings, then you
see a vector field, a massless
vector field in the spectrum
plus an infinite of [INAUDIBLE].
And when you quantize
closed strings,
then you see massless
spin-2 particles,
which is a graviton in
your massless spectrum
plus infinite number
of [INAUDIBLE].
So that essentially is the
essence of string theory,
is that the strings
contain graviton
in a quantum mechanical way.
So it should be consistent--
should be considered
as a serial quantum gravity.
So today, we start talking
about another object
in string theory.
It's called the D-branes.
OK?
So we discussed open
strings, so let's
go back to the open string.
For the open string, say
after we fixed the [INAUDIBLE]
to be flat, the
[INAUDIBLE] action
can be written as the following.
OK?
So you can-- when
you get the-- when
you obtain the equation
of motion for x,
you will have
something like this.
So you need to do an
integration by parts
plus a total derivative term,
or plus a total derivative term
until the derivative term we
induce a term on the boundary
if you have an open string.
Say at sigma equal to 0 and pi.
OK?
So this is still d tau.
And so from this term, you
get equation of motion.
And then you induce a
boundary term, evaluate it.
If it's open string, there's
two boundaries, at 0 and pi.
To do such a boundary
term at the boundary,
we need to also get
rid of-- otherwise,
the equation of motion
is not satisfied.
And what we discussed
is [INAUDIBLE]
Neumann boundary conditions.
It's just taking the pi of
sigma equal to 0, pi of sigma x
mu to be 0.
But in general, for
any mu, say for any mu,
you have a choice of
four boundary conditions.
You can choose delta
x mu equal to 0,
or partial sigma
x mu equal to 0.
Say and sigma equal to 0.
And you have the same
choices at sigma equal to pi.
So altogether, you have
actually four possible boundary
conditions for each direction.
So for each direction, you
have four possible boundary
conditions.
If you can see the all
possible directions,
there are many, many
different boundary conditions.
OK?
There are, in principle,
many, many different boundary
conditions.
So let's now look at what the
other boundary conditions mean.
OK?
We looked at the case which
the-- you just imposed this
everywhere, at both sigma equal
to 0 and sigma equal to pi,
and the four directions.
But now let us explore
these more general boundary
conditions.
First let's just quickly look at
what this boundary-- so this is
called Dirichlet
boundary condition,
this is called the Neumann.
So first let's look at what does
this boundary condition mean.
OK?
So if we have-- say let's
consider some direction,
i, set delta xi equal to 0.
Say at sigma equal to
0, say tau equal to 0.
So this is the example of
this Dirichlet boundary
condition in the i direction.
Say suppose that sigma equal to
0, you have-- you impose this.
So what this means is that
the vibration of xi at sigma
equal to 0 at all
time does not change.
So tau is like a parameter
I should watch it-- time,
the watch it motion.
So this tells you that, at
all time, the value of the xi
does not change at the endpoint.
So what this means,
this directly
translates into xi
sigma equal to 0,
and tau should be a constant.
OK?
Should be a constant.
So this is the
Dirichlet condition.
And so let's look
at some examples
to understand a little
bit more explicitly
what this kind of
condition-- want
this Dirichlet condition means.
OK?
So let's first
consider the example.
Say suppose in all directions,
say from 0 to d minus 2,
OK, we use-- suppose use
Neumann boundary condition
as what we did before for
both sigma equal to 0 and pi.
But for the last
coordinate, [INAUDIBLE]
xt minus 1, so let's impose the
Dirichlet boundary condition.
So let's take it to be
A at sigma-- both sigma
and 0 equal to pi.
OK?
So for the moment, let's
take the boundary condition
to be same at both
sigma equal to 0 and pi.
So let's look at what
did this condition means.
Let's look at this example.
So what this condition means--
so let's draw a figure.
So, I cannot draw
many directions.
In particular, I cannot
draw 6x26 dimensions.
So let me call the
horizontal axis as all the--
the connection of all the
dimensions up to d minus 2.
And under this axis
is the d minus 1.
OK?
Then the endpoint, the x d minus
1 equal to a at the endpoint--
so suppose that this is
the line of x equal to a.
So suppose this is the
hypersurface for x equals-- x d
minus 1 equal to a, then that
boundary condition tells you
that whatever open
string the motion,
the endpoint must be restricted
to this hypersurface.
OK?
So that's what this--
geometrically, what
this condition means.
It just says, let's
consider xt minus 1
equal to a, which is a
hypersurface in spacetime,
and then this condition means
that the endpoint of the string
must be restricted
to this surface.
The interior of
the string can be
any-- can be out-- can
have no restriction,
but the endpoint have
to be on this surface.
OK?
Is this clear?
OK.
So you can generalize.
So this is the first example.
You can generalize.
Let's consider x from
0 to some value, p.
Of course, p is smaller
than the total number
of dimensions, which is n
for sigma at 0 and the pi.
And then the rest-- say xp plus
1, xp plus 2, to xp minus 1,
these directions we impose the
Dirichlet boundary conditions.
And then let me call
this one back to a.
So I'm back to a.
For both sigma
equal to 0 and pi.
OK?
So a is just some constant
vector of the same dimension
as the number of x here.
The same as the
number of x here.
And this is just
a more general way
to impose this to
more directions.
OK?
Is this notation clear?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is there
a repeated superscript?
HONG LIU: Oh, sorry.
It's p plus 2.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Maybe
do we talk about,
like, a different
0 pi behaviors,
or is that not interesting?
HONG LIU: No, we
will talk about that.
Let's look at the
simple case first.
So is this notation clear?
So again, I can do this on
the similar plots like this.
So now horizontal axis
[INAUDIBLE] x 0 to p,
and the vertical
axis I do p plus 1
all the way to d minus 1.
So now those axes are
multiple dimensional.
And then this
specifies-- so this a
specifies a p plus 1 dimensional
hypersurface-- surface.
So the value of those
coordinates are fixed,
but the value of those
coordinates can be arbitrary.
So this p plus 1
free parameter here.
OK?
And so this is a p plus
1 dimensional surface
in the spacetime.
And this condition
means that the endpoint
of whatever open string must
be restricted to this surface.
OK?
Is the picture clear?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Hmm?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
We are talking
about how to impose
the-- what's the meaning of
imposing the Dirichlet boundary
condition.
Instead of Neumann
boundary condition.
So we now impose the
Dirichlet boundary condition,
which goes one into the
[INAUDIBLE] of the endpoint
should be 0.
And then this can be
specified by the endpoint
if you take some constant value.
And so that's the
geometric way to think
about these different
Dirichlet boundary conditions.
So if you look at this
naively, so previously, when
we can see the Neumann boundary
condition for all directions,
then the string-- then there's
no restriction to the string.
Then the string
can move anywhere.
So now when you-- when
in some directions
we impose the
Dirichlet condition,
then we see that-- then
the motion of the string
get restricted, and
that this endpoint now
have to [INAUDIBLE] some soft
dimension of the spacetime.
OK?
So at first sight, this may
seem to be a nonsensical thing
to do.
Just say-- you ask
why somehow I have
to restrict some open
strings to some sub-manifold
in the spacetime.
So why should I do that?
In particular, that breaks
the Lorentz symmetry.
In particular, that
breaks Lorentzian.
So the nice thing about the
Neumann boundary condition
we did before, in more
directions, so that
respects Lorentz symmetry.
And once we introduce some
directions to the Dirichlet
boundary condition,
you necessarily
break Lorentz symmetry, because
we select out some directions
with some others.
OK?
And so you necessarily
break Lorentz symmetry.
You also break translation
symmetry because of the-- you
have to specify
some sub-manifold.
You also break the
translation symmetry.
So at first sight, this seems
to be a nonsensical thing to do.
So that's why, for many
years, actually people did not
look at this object,
even though for a person
to work out string
theory on the first day,
you should already realize those
are the boundary conditions.
But for many years,
people did not
pay attention to this kind
of boundary conditions.
It turns out that
standard of conditions
plays a key role
in string theory.
And the key is to take a
slight different perspective
at [INAUDIBLE] sub-manifold.
OK?
So now what you
should think about
is-- and now what you think
about is the following.
So you think about maybe
for the whole spacetime,
the whole spacetime,
only closed string
is the most natural object,
because it can move anywhere.
But then there's
some special places
in the spacetime,
some kind of defect.
And at those defect,
the closed string
can break to become open string.
OK?
Can become open string.
And if you take
that perspective,
then that gives special
meaning to such kind
of special sub-manifold
which open string can end,
then there's some
kind of object there.
Because of the existence
of certain object there,
then the open string
can end there.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So indeed, if you have
that perspective, then instead
of having it lie
along hyperplanes,
is it more natural
to have it just lie
upon some other manifold?
HONG LIU: Oh, you
can-- yeah, I'm
just taking you--
I'm just sending you
the simplest example.
AUDIENCE: Sure, sure.
HONG LIU: And once you realize
in this simple example,
then you can generalize
the [INAUDIBLE]
complicated scenario
you can imagine.
Now let's just think about,
in the simplest case, imposing
those boundary
conditions become natural
if you think those
places in spacetime
are special places which
something can happen.
It's not the same
as other places.
And to say those
[INAUDIBLE] give a name.
So you imagine--
so for example, you
can imagine some spacetime
defect sitting at, say,
this xp plus 1, x equal to
a, sitting at that location.
So where open string can end.
So such a defect,
we'll call it D-brane.
We give a name.
So D is clear because
it's Dirichlet boundary
condition, and the brane because
it's some extended surface.
OK?
And so we often use a
notation to say Dp-brane.
So p denotes the [INAUDIBLE]
spatial dimensions
along the brane.
OK?
So in this case, there's
p spatial dimensions
along the plane-- along this
brane, so we call it Dp-brane.
OK?
So right now, Dp-brane
is merely just a place
which impose a boundary
conditions which
open strings can end.
But we will soon see
that actually a Dp-brane
is a dynamic object, and it's
actually a dynamic object.
And this actually can move,
can fluctuate, can jump around,
et cetera.
OK?
And so also from
this perspective,
our previous Neumann
boundary condition,
if we have Neumann
in all direction,
so if we have Neumann boundary
condition in all directions,
then in this case the open
string can end everywhere.
End anywhere.
From this new perspective, we
call this space-filling brane.
We call this actually
a space-filling brane.
OK?
So the Dirichlet boundary--
the Neumann boundary condition
we considered before should
be considered as actually you
fill the whole spacetime
with such a brane,
and then the string can, in
principle, move anywhere.
So for example, in
the bosonic string
we talked about before, this
group because one and two
are D 25 brane, so D 25
brane because there's
25 spatial dimensions.
OK?
Such a brane when you
impose the Neumann boundary
condition in all directions.
Or if you are in the
super string, which
the total number
of spacetime is 10,
and then the spatial number--
spatial dimension is nine,
then you have D9-- then
these other D9 branes.
Any questions about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
boundary conditions,
they're imposed at the
quantum level, right?
It's not just that the
classical solution has
to have its endpoints
on this D-brane,
but it's the fluctuations
around it [INAUDIBLE]
solution that we consider?
HONG LIU: We will
talk about that.
We will talk about that.
Any other questions?
Good.
So let me make a note.
You can, in principle,
impose the Dirichlet boundary
condition in any
direction you like, except
in the x0 direction.
OK?
It's because x0
cannot be a constant.
x0 have-- so x0 is a
time, is our real time
in the Minkowski space.
So the string moves in
this Minkowski spacetime,
and this x0 is that time.
And the time cannot stand still.
OK?
And in order to have this,
you needed that location
to stand still.
And the time cannot stand still.
So this cannot be a constant.
So you cannot impose the
Dirichlet boundary condition
in the time direction.
So the smallest in the Minkowski
spacetime, the smallest
would be at D0 brane, which we
impose the Dirichlet boundary
condition in all spatial
directions except in time.
In time, you always
impose the Neumann.
Then the smallest
situation will be called
D0 brane, which is a point.
And then the open string
can end on this point.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I have question.
So this idea about calling the
Neumann boundary conditions
to D25 branes or D9 branes.
So this is a little
bit perplexing,
because it seems like not
imposing Dirichlet boundary
conditions, this implies that
not imposing Dirichlet boundary
conditions is equivalent to
applying Neumann boundary
conditions, which is not--
they're not, like-- I mean,
they're like mutually exclusive.
It's not like--
so I mean, I don't
understand why it is that--
so does this thing behave
like a 24 brane?
Like, does it have the same
properties as, like, a 24 brane
or something like that?
HONG LIU: Sorry, which?
You mean 25 brane.
AUDIENCE: So what I'm saying is
that it seems that the Neumann
boundary conditions have
a different character
than-- like a
different flavor of how
they work than the Dirichlet
boundary conditions.
So it just seems strange
to me that you would still
call it a brane, like a D 25
brane when you impose them
or not.
HONG LIU: No.
So in those cases, in
those cases-- for example,
in this case, which we Neumann
boundary conditions in all
the other directions
except one, then
this is a 24
dimensional-- then this
is a 25 dimensional manifold
which the string can end on.
And I just--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see, of course.
So, right.
You have to apply the Neumann
boundary conditions to all
of the other [INAUDIBLE].
OK, I understand.
Yeah.
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so it's-- yeah.
Any other questions?
OK, good.
So now let's consider
more complicated--
slightly more complicated
boundary conditions.
So by introducing
this D-brane, now you
can actually have all different
possible boundary conditions.
As we said here, there--
for each direction,
you can have in principle
four possible choices.
And then if you
have [INAUDIBLE],
so for time direction you don't.
But for the 25 dimensions,
25 spatial dimensions.
And each dimension,
you have four choices,
and you have four to the
power 25 possible choices
of different
boundary conditions.
Now let's talk about the
other boundary conditions.
So by using the
picture of D-brane,
we can talk about them all.
We can talk about them all.
So then let's consider
model 1 branes.
OK?
So let's consider the situation
we have two such Dp-brane.
So this direction is
still x1-- x01 to p.
And then this is all
the other directions.
So suppose we have a brane
at a and another brane at b,
at the vector specified by b.
OK?
So now in this case, we can
have four types of open strings.
We can have four
types of open strings.
For example, I can have an
open string which ends of b.
I'm going to have an
open string end on a.
But then I can also
have an open string
which goes from b to a, and
for open string from a to b.
OK?
So in this case, the
boundary condition
would be the x01 to p is
still a Neumann boundary
condition for both sigma equal
to 0 and sigma equal to pi.
But for the other
directions, you
can have either-- your sigma
0 can either be in a or b.
Or sigma, you could do
pi can either be a or b.
So that gives you the
four types of strings.
OK?
That gives you four types
of different strings.
Now you also can see the
branes of different dimensions.
So now you can see the
branes of [INAUDIBLE].
So for example, say
suppose let's think
of the two directions,
D minus 2 and D minus 1.
And let's suppose all
the other directions
are in the Neumann direction.
So this can see the
two kinds of branes.
One is extended in the D
minus 2 direction [INAUDIBLE]
some value of D minus 1.
And then you can
see another brane,
which is localized in both
D minus 1 and D minus 2.
OK?
Then you can again have
four types of strings.
[INAUDIBLE] and the
ending between these two.
So again, you can see
the [INAUDIBLE] string
because we can see the
[INAUDIBLE] string.
So you can again see
the string like that.
So let me call this
brane 1, this brane 2.
So let's consider
the 1-2 string.
It reaches from 1 to 2.
Then the 1-2 string, with the
corresponding to the boundary
condition, say at D minus
2, say at sigma equal to 0,
you impose the Neumann
boundary condition
because it can move freely
in the D minus 2 direction.
And but in the-- at
sigma equal to pi, then
this should be
fixed at some value.
So let's suppose,
say, this is a 1, b1.
Then add to that,
we are fixed at a1.
OK?
So this is 1-2 string.
Then you can have one end
which is a Neumann boundary
condition, but the other end
which is Dirichlet boundary
condition.
OK?
Is this clear to you?
And then for this 2-1 string
that will be opposite,
for the 2-1 string for the
D minus 2 direction at sigma
equal to 0 will be the
Dirichlet condition,
but at sigma equal to pi would
be the Neumann condition.
Any questions about this?
So these are pretty simple.
You just need to get used to
it and spend a couple minutes
drawing a couple of diagrams.
Then you will be an expert.
You will be an expert.
This is pretty elementary.
So important remark.
So a Dp-brane, as
we said before,
it breaks translation symmetry.
Translation and the
Lorentz symmetries.
OK?
Of the original Minkowski
spacetime to your sub-group.
So the subgroup is
that you have-- still
have translational symmetry
and the Lorentz symmetry
along the brane direction.
So along the brane
direction, you still
can translate-- your
string can still
translate in that direction.
And there's still Lorentz
symmetry in that direction.
So there's still Poincare
symmetry in 1,p-- 1 comma p--
so in the time and the p spatial
dimensions along the brane.
And then you have rotational
symmetries in the direction
transverse to the brane.
So that's D minus 1 minus p.
So that's the rotation
among those coordinates.
So you can have the
Lorentz symmetry
along those directions,
then the rotational symmetry
is along those directions.
OK?
So this is for Dp-brane.
So this is the
remaining symmetry.
So this is remaining
symmetry say if you have
a Dp-brane in the spacetime.
Of course, if you have
multiple Dp-brane, et cetera,
then it's broken even more.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] branes
are [INAUDIBLE] open not
[INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Oh.
Yeah, we can talk--
here, I'm just
talking about the
simplest situation.
I'm imposing the simplest
boundary condition, just
like these kind of
boundary conditions.
And then these kind
of boundary conditions
is-- applies to the
infinite-- yeah,
you can-- once later we
talk about the D-brane can
be dynamically excited, then
you can see the complicated
configurations.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
boundary condition [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
x plus [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Ah.
You are saying
something like this--
you're saying some
combination of this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
x plus [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That can happen.
That does not happen in the
straight Minkowski space,
because in the straight
Minkowski space
this is the action.
So you only have
one or the other.
But if you, say, have
Minkowski but you
turn on some
electric field, then
you can actually have such kind
of mixed boundary conditions.
Yeah.
Just they exist-- it depends
on the specific dynamical
situation.
So this is empty,
flat Minkowski space,
then you can only have
those boundary conditions.
AUDIENCE: And when [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: When [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: That I'm not sure.
That is different.
Yeah, because that does
not satisfy that boundary
condition.
And so we have a look at
the specific situation.
We have to look at the
specific situation.
Just for the flat
Minkowski space,
these are the only boundary
conditions you can have.
And we will not
have-- we will not
be able to do it in
this course, but you
can see the situation because
of the-- in open string,
you can have
electromagnetic field.
You can have a photon.
So you can, in principle, turn
on electromagnetic fields.
And then we modify the
boundary condition.
Then you can have actually
mixed boundary conditions.
AUDIENCE: Do people
ever consider
this is a [INAUDIBLE] between
two D-branes as a [INAUDIBLE]
defect?
Because [INAUDIBLE] between--
HONG LIU: You mean string
between different-- string
before-- between
different D-branes.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
HONG LIU: You can see that
the D-branes themselves
have topological defect, rather
than the string between them
has the topological defect.
The D-branes
themselves are defects.
Strings are just-- as we will
talk about-- we will talk about
it now, the strings
on the D-brane,
they're just the
excitations of the D-branes.
So now after talking about
those boundary conditions,
then we can again go
through the procedure
of quantizing open strings
with those boundary conditions.
Then we see what do we get.
Now let's talk about
the open string
spectrum on the Dp-brane.
So as you can see already
from those pictures,
because of the restriction on
the endpoints, so essentially
those strings, they
can only move along
the direction of the brane.
They can only move in the
direction along the brane.
So essentially, they
can be considered
as living on the brane.
OK?
So those open strings are
living on those Dp-branes.
OK?
So when we quantize
those open strings,
then we will get the excitations
of those open strings,
the state of those open
strings, on the D-branes.
OK?
So let me first
introduce some notations.
Previously, we have the notation
mu refers to all directions.
So now I separate into
[INAUDIBLE] and a.
And [INAUDIBLE] is the Neumann
boundary-- Neumann directions
from 0 to p.
And the a are the Dirichlet
directions from p plus 1 to D
minus 1.
So there's D minus
1 minus p of them.
So D minus 1 minus p of them.
So for the Neumann
boundary condition,
it's just identical
to what we had before.
So let me just write
it down to remind you.
OK.
So these are the, say,
the most general solution.
So in this case in particular,
if you remember you have xa
you could do xr.
So the left moving
and right moving
are the same, controlled
by the same function.
And so that's why you get
this cosine sig cosine.
And when you take the derivative
of a sigma becomes sine,
then vanishes at the endpoints.
OK?
So for this story, it's just
exactly identical as before.
So now let's look at the
Dirichlet conditions.
So for the Dirichlet
conditions, let's again
write down the most general
possible boundary conditions
for Dirichlet boundary--
yeah, first write down
the most general solution
for such a field.
So you have xa then 2ipa tau.
Then you have [INAUDIBLE]
tau [INAUDIBLE] sigma
and [INAUDIBLE] sigma.
OK?
But now the boundary
condition we need to impose
is xa at sigma
equal to 0 and pi.
Sigma 0 tau and sigma
pi tau equal to ba.
So here, I call them
a, but let me call them
b because [INAUDIBLE]
write a to the index a.
So let me just them
b, the vector b.
OK?
So now we have to impose
this boundary condition.
So you can immediately see
that because of this boundary
condition xa have to be ba.
OK, xa have to be ba.
And this pa have to be 0.
pa have to be 0, otherwise you
won't satisfy this condition,
because this changes with time.
And then you want
the sum of them
to be 0 at x equal
to-- sigma equal to 0.
So that gives you xao
equal to [INAUDIBLE] xr.
So this is from the boundary
condition at sigma equal to 0.
OK?
And then the boundary
condition is sigma equal to pi,
you deduce both of them are
periodic boundary conditions.
They are periodic
functions in 2pi.
OK?
They're periodic in 2pi.
You can see it easily.
So at the tau--
sigma equal to 0,
we just have xr tau plus
xao tau equal to-- yeah,
it should be equal to 0, so you
xao equal to [INAUDIBLE] xr.
So now, you can just
write down explicitly
just-- still, this is a
periodic function in 2pi,
so the expansion is
essentially the same.
So the only difference
for those directions
is that now you
have b alpha, ba.
Now you don't have this
term, because this term is 0.
And then a not equal to 0
alpha [INAUDIBLE] divided by n
minus [INAUDIBLE]
tau sine in sigma.
OK, there's some pre-factors
here I forgot to write.
Some alpha prime
[INAUDIBLE] by convention,
let's not worry
about those things.
OK?
So now you do quantization.
So the quantization in
Neumann boundary condition,
of course identical
to before-- oh yeah,
first let me just
explain the pa equal 0.
I just want to make one remark.
So this is, of course, expected.
Because if the string is
limited in moving on this plane,
then of course it cannot move
in the perpendicular direction,
so cannot have central mass,
momentum in the-- so cannot
have central mass, momentum in
the perpendicular direction.
So this is indeed what
we intuitively expect.
OK?
The central mass momentum can
only be in the one direction,
or can only be in the
Neumann directions.
So the quantization of the
Neumann boundary condition
is exactly the same as before.
And actually, quantization
in Dirichlet directions
which this is set up also the
same, also exactly the same.
Because essentially the
only change is cosine
sigma goes to sine sigma.
You can walk through
that procedure,
and you find that
nothing really changes.
So it's exactly the
same as that of n.
OK?
In particular, the
commutation relations
between all those modes
does not change at all,
just [INAUDIBLE]
exactly the same
as what you would have
in the Neumann case.
So this is also [INAUDIBLE].
This is [INAUDIBLE].
So imposing such
boundary conditions,
essentially you're only
restricted to the central mass
motion, so you can no longer
move in the perpendicular
directions.
But the string can oscillate.
But string can still oscillate
in all 10 dimensions.
There's no difference in the
way the string oscillates.
And so strings still
oscillate in 10 dimensions,
so everything is the same.
Yeah.
A string is still oscillating
in all directions.
In particular, the zero
point energy is the same.
Zero point energy on the
worksheet is the same.
OK?
So this means that the mass
formula we derived before
for the Neumann
boundary condition
will exactly apply
without any change.
OK?
Without any change.
In particular, the
mass of the spectrum
will also be essentially--
the mass of the spectrum
will also be essentially
exactly the same as before.
One second.
So let me just mention one
point, that this is identical.
This is identical.
This is actually related to
that for the Dirichlet boundary
condition on both sides.
This is still a
periodic boundary--
a periodic function in 2pi.
And so you get this.
In such a case, say if one
endpoint is the Neumann
boundary condition
but the other endpoint
is a Dirichlet
boundary condition,
then the story is a
little bit more subtle.
OK?
And then you actually get
to the-- then the frequency
of each modes become half
integer rather than integer.
And then you will get the
difference [INAUDIBLE],
and there the spectrum
will change, et cetera.
OK?
So I will not do it now.
Maybe I will put it in
your [INAUDIBLE] p set,
so that you can do it yourself.
Yeah?
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
question was what happens
when p equals 0 [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, for the p
equal to 0, yeah,
indeed it's a little bit
tricky to do the [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
Yeah, for p equal to 0, it's
tricky to do the [INAUDIBLE].
But you can do-- using other
quantization procedures,
then you can do the same thing.
Yeah, but the conclusion does
not change between different
p's.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Maybe I missed this,
but for the two different brane
that you have a string going
from one brane to another--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You said from a point
to a brane, the story changes.
What about, like, from
one brane to another?
Is it exactly the same
as this, or is it--
HONG LIU: Oh yeah, that's
also a good question,
which I might already
have something
like this in the current p set.
If not, it's something
I'll put in the next p set
because you asked.
Yeah, you see there's a
distance between them.
So now you actually need
to include the sigma term.
Now you actually need to
include the sigma term here
to account this difference.
Because now the 0 and the
pi is no longer the same.
Yeah, here I don't need
to put in the sigma term
because the 0 and
the pi are the same.
AUDIENCE: So the zero
point would change--
HONG LIU: Yeah, zero
point energy will change.
And essentially, it's given
by the mass of the strings
stretched between them.
Yeah, so that's-- yeah, that's
a very instructive exercise.
Actually maybe I already
put in the current p set.
I don't remember.
Anyway.
Other questions?
Good.
So now let's look at the-- more
explicitly at the open string
spectrum.
So again, it's the same thing.
You just [INAUDIBLE]
and 1, mu 1.
You can act m1
times n k, mu k, mk.
The only difference is
now your vacuum state
is only-- can only have momentum
in the p alpha direction.
That's essentially
the only difference.
OK?
And again, the mass
square now it just matters
p alpha-- p alpha.
OK, only around the
Neumann directions.
So this is really--
then each mode
on the string-- each
oscillation mode of the string
now should really be
corresponding to a particle
or field in p plus 1 dimensional
world-volume of the Dp-brane.
OK?
So we call-- this
is the world-volume.
We call the directions,
all these directions
together, as the
world-volume of the Dp-brane.
So since the string can only
move along the Dp-brane,
so they can only correspond
into the field of particles
within the Dp-brane.
They cannot move in
the opposite direction.
They cannot move in the
perpendicular direction.
OK?
So [INAUDIBLE]
lives on the brane.
OK?
And in this-- then
all of those things
may be considered as the
excitations of the branes.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] string
can be part of the excitation.
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
Because you can excite certain
strings and not excite strings,
et cetera.
And they're all moving
along the brane.
And the important thing
is that the states
should fall into repetitions
now of this symmetry,
because that's the only
remaining symmetry.
[INAUDIBLE] when p
under the rotation
in the transverse directions.
OK?
And again, just by
this, you can show
that it actually makes sense
only in the 26th dimension.
OK?
Again, makes sense only
in the 26th dimension.
So now let's again look
at the massless states.
So as I mentioned before,
the mass [INAUDIBLE]
exactly the same as before,
because the oscillation
modes behaves exactly the same.
So the mass [INAUDIBLE] exact
behaves the same as before.
So the massless states,
that is the following.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When we say the
particles in [INAUDIBLE]
dimensional world-volume--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But [INAUDIBLE]
particles [INAUDIBLE] object,
whereas the open
string can-- you
know, one end of the
open string located
at one point [INAUDIBLE]
the other one [INAUDIBLE]
very far away.
But is that picture [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: No.
That's a good question.
So when I say particles,
I'm talking about the center
of mass motion.
OK?
Therefore, each
oscillation modes
that you see, that's
corresponding to-- yeah,
for particular
oscillation modes, then
the-- other than those
quantum number-- yeah,
let me finish this.
I will answer that question.
I will write this
down explicitly.
So let's talk about
massless states.
So again, using [INAUDIBLE].
So again, we are
using the [INAUDIBLE].
You can separate the [INAUDIBLE]
and i in the Neumann direction.
And in the Dirichlet
direction, again it's
just the p plus 1 to D minus 1.
OK?
And then the massless modes
would be the same as before.
You have [INAUDIBLE]
1i acting on p alpha.
And the alpha minus 1
a acting on p alpha.
And the plus infinite number.
Plus infinite number
of massless modes.
OK?
So let me just
illustrate this point.
So this [INAUDIBLE] as
before, the [INAUDIBLE]
further breaks this Poincare
symmetry to only a sub-group.
But you can already
see from here
this must be corresponding
to a vector particle.
So this is like a
massless vector.
Massless vector.
Yeah, so to answer your
question, so example,
for typical modes like this,
the only quantum number
you have is p alpha and
this vector indices.
This vector index.
So from the perspective
of the quantum number--
and this really is just
like a vector particle.
Just like a vector particle.
And then you can describe it
by a vector field, et cetera.
It is very good question.
Say suppose in this situation
which I have a string,
suppose a string is
really very known.
It's very big.
Then I should be able to see
this one-dimensional structure.
Indeed, then that
means that, even
though this corresponding-- this
is just corresponding to one
particular mode of the string.
And to see the string structure
you have to be able to see,
you can excite this into other
different modes, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
stretch the string.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean, [INAUDIBLE]--
HONG LIU: Yeah, stretching
the string corresponding
to exciting the string
in a different way.
It means leaving this
particular state.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
I'm talking about
the interpretation
of this particular
state, which is
[INAUDIBLE] spacetime particle.
AUDIENCE: Actually
this data conversely
decided the other
configuration of--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
It determines all
the configuration.
the oscillation modes
of the open string.
Just the other
oscillation modes,
they are all not excited.
But of course, if
when [INAUDIBLE]
this one-dimensional
object [INAUDIBLE]
find the ways to excite them.
And then you know this
is not a particle,
it's a one-dimensional
object, et cetera.
But in order to see this
one-dimensional structure,
you have to probe the final
structure that just loads
quantum numbers.
If those are the only quantum
numbers you can probe,
then [INAUDIBLE] particle.
So this is the massless vector.
But now those guys,
they have index a, which
is not in the Poincare here.
So those are now scalar fields.
OK?
Those are scalar fields on the
world-volume of the D-branes.
OK?
So now we find--
so previously, when
we can see the all Neumann
directions, we only
see a vector field.
So moving more 26th dimension.
But now-- so these
massless modes,
they give rise to
a vector field,
the massless vector
field A alpha,
and D minus p minus 1
scalar fields phi a.
OK?
So essentially, when
you introduce D-brane
compared to the space-fitting
brane cage, which
we can see the before in
the Neumann direction,
just some component
of those cage fields
now become the oscillation
in the transverse direction,
and now they just essentially
become scalar fields.
OK?
Is this clear?
So now instead you have
a smaller vector field,
plus a bunch of scalar fields.
As we said before,
[INAUDIBLE] defective action,
so the [INAUDIBLE] defective
action for such massless modes
must be-- have the
structure, say--
so this is in the p plus
1 dimensional world-volume
of the string, say,
of a Maxwell series.
And they're just the same
as with scalar fields.
And then of course, they are
more complicated contributions.
Just this is a no energy.
Then the structure
of those excitations,
they must be described by
this kind of low-energy factor
series.
And this is, again,
just determined
by the universality
of massless modes.
So now there's a
very-- so now let me--
the first node-- let me
emphasize this point,
is that the number of massless
modes, massless scalar fields.
So we have such a
bunch of scalar fields.
It's exactly the number
of transverse directions
to the D-brane.
OK?
So essentially, associated
with each transverse direction
you have scalar excitations.
You have massless scalar fields.
OK?
So let me emphasize this point.
So those scalar fields, some of
you maybe already have guessed,
they have a very simple
physical explanation--
physical interpretation.
And those scalar
fields, they can
be considered as describing the
motions and the fluctuations
of the D-brane in the
transverse directions.
OK?
So for each
transverse direction,
you have such massless
scalar fields.
And each of scalar
fields-- so more precisely,
so more explicitly, just
as a cartoon picture,
suppose let's
consider, say, the p
minus 1 direction,
p plus 1 direction.
This direction, p
plus 1 direction.
So suppose you have a
D-brane sitting here
at some value of a.
OK?
So when we impose the Dirichlet
boundary condition-- yeah,
so those are the
x1 01 p directions.
OK?
Yeah.
Yeah, this is the other
x0 and p directions.
You have a D-brane sitting
here at some value of a.
So when we impose the
Dirichlet boundary conditions,
that boundary condition
does not depend
on the value of x0 and p.
So they're the same everywhere.
So that's why I draw
it flat, exact flat.
But now, if you have some
excitations in the phi
p plus 1 direction,
so phi p plus 1
is a field in the
world-volume of the half--
can have p alpha momentum.
You can go to coordinate space.
Then their function's
just x1, xp.
OK?
xi, xp.
And then the profile
of this phi essentially
tells you that the D-brane--
say if you have a scalar field
excitation like this, then
the shape of the D-brane
actually is no
longer strictly flat.
Actually have a profile
given by these scalar fields.
So we are not justify
this precise--
so this can be justified
mathematically to really show
that this is the case.
OK?
And I will not do
that here, but let
me just mention some
support for this picture.
So-- OK.
So first you can show
at [INAUDIBLE] level
having such excitations-- OK?
So having such excitations,
so we can just call it
[INAUDIBLE] excitations.
So this is a picture
in momentum space.
[INAUDIBLE] excitations
modifies the Dirichlet boundary
condition.
OK?
So this you can show explicitly.
So this is first point, which
I will not go into there.
And the second point is that
you can actually work out
the precise pre-factor.
There's a way, say by doing
string theory calculation,
say by computing
the [INAUDIBLE],
there's a way you
can actually work out
the pre-factor,
precise pre-factor.
So let me call this
the equation star.
So you can actually work out--
so that was just by general--
this is just by
general principle.
Say if you have a massless
spectrum, then the [INAUDIBLE]
must behave like this.
But this pre-factor
is not fixed.
OK?
But you can actually, with
the interpretation phi,
[INAUDIBLE] fluctuations of this
Dirichlet boundary condition,
you can actually fix the
precise pre-factor here.
So working out the
[INAUDIBLE] you
can show that actually
this action can
be written as the following.
Tp-- again, it's integrated
only over the [INAUDIBLE]
of the D-branes, p plus 1.
And actually first we
find actually there's
a constant term.
We will call that
action precisely.
And then you have this F term
under this-- and let me-- yeah,
actually I should
have done it there.
So there is a summation
a over here, right?
So this Tp, this
pre-factor, is actually--
we can work out the
precise pre-factor.
And this pre-factor is given
by the mass of our Dp-brane
per unit volume.
Or in other words,
the brane tension.
So I will explain where
does this come from, where--
how do we define brane tension.
But for now, let
me just introduce
this concept of brane tension.
So if you work out
the pre-factor,
you find the pre-factor is
precisely the brane tension,
OK?
Brane tension.
So now if you look at this
equation, so then this 1,
it's just like a
static mass term.
This 1 is like a
So you also find this 1 in
this [INAUDIBLE] action.
But this 1 is very important
because of the-- so this 1
is like static term.
And now if you
look at this term,
so now if you consider the
situation which A alpha is
equal to 0-- so you don't have
an excitation of the vector
field, but phi a
only depend on t.
Only depend on the time.
And then this
effective action then
will become Tp, then
the volume of the p,
then dt 1/2 phi dot a square.
OK?
And so Vp is the
volume of Dp-brane.
Volume of the Dp-brane.
And this tension times
Dp-brane-- so this
is just the mass.
So this is just the mass.
So you can rewrite this just
1/2 and p-brane phi dot square.
And then D-brane [INAUDIBLE]
Tp times the volume.
So you see, this is
precisely like a particle.
Like the whole brane moving--
the [INAUDIBLE] motion
moving of some object.
OK?
So again, this give
you the interpretation
that the phi can be interpreted
as the [INAUDIBLE] describe
the motion of the brane.
OK?
OK.
So do you have any
questions about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
introduce the dynamics of brane
from [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: If we [INAUDIBLE]
brane [INAUDIBLE],
then with the
pre-factors [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: No.
Those pre-factors depend
on your normalization.
Those pre-factors
depend on normalization.
So you can normalize them
in some particular way.
You can normalize
them-- here, what
I'm saying is that there is a
specific normalization, which
then the phi can
precisely be interpreted
as the motion of the D-brane--
yeah, phi always corresponding
to the motion of the D-brane,
but this specific normalization
in phi can be really interpreted
as a dynamical version
of this coordinate in
the transverse direction.
And with that
normalization, then you
see that this
[INAUDIBLE] action is
like the motion of
a massive object.
OK?
It's like the motion
of a massive object.
And this gives you
the confirmation
that the phi indeed is
degrees freedom-- should
be considered degrees
freedom to describe
the motion of the D-brane.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That's-- I mean, that
is only in the [INAUDIBLE].
If that analogy
continued, [INAUDIBLE]
higher excitations of those
closed-- open strings?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
So that's a good question,
which I don't have time
to discuss now but
I can-- but I will
describe at the beginning
of next lecture.
So this is a no-energy story.
Then you can actually include
a subset of higher-order terms.
Then you find that
there's an infinite number
of higher-order
terms you can sum,
and then this precisely
generalize to the motion
of a [INAUDIBLE] object.
Yeah, because if you want to--
yeah, because this is no-energy
[INAUDIBLE] have to
be non-relativistic.
But then you can
generalize, generally
if you sum over an infinite
number of higher terms, then
this describes [INAUDIBLE]
motion of object.
And again, that's another
independent confirmation
that this is the-- describe
the motion of the D-brane.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I'm kind of
fundamentally confused
about how-- so we started
with a D-brane which
was a topological defect
in our background manifold.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So like a
[INAUDIBLE] or something.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And we are
looking at motion of strings
in this background manifold.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And this
is-- so why do
we all of a sudden have
the string motion affect
the background?
Like we never even introduced
any coupling to the background.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
So that's precisely-- so
this is a very good question.
This is precisely the remarkable
thing about this string theory.
So yeah, so I was going
to say at the beginning
of next lecture, but
now let me say it.
So at the beginning, you
introduce the D-brane just
by some rigid
boundary conditions.
Some rigid boundary conditions.
And looks like this is
a non-dynamical object
because you are introducing
some rigid boundary conditions.
But now, when you quantize
the strings under D-branes,
and then you find that those
strings now give the D-brane
itself [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Is it because
there's a graviton here?
HONG LIU: No, it has nothing
to do with gravitons.
[INAUDIBLE] do with graviton.
Generally, you start with
rigid boundary conditions.
But now you find [INAUDIBLE]
boundary conditions.
Then you can generate-- then
you have some excitations.
Then the coherent motions
of these excitations
now give this object dynamics.
So that's a precisely remarkable
thing about string theory.
AUDIENCE: What if you have
two strings both ending
on the same brane?
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
No, this is including
all the strings.
You can have as many
strings as you want.
AUDIENCE: Well I
mean, we're quantizing
one particular object,
and we're looking
at a spectrum of a single
string starting here--
HONG LIU: Yeah, each string
have such excitations.
AUDIENCE: But then
each different string
will generate a different
dynamics for the--
HONG LIU: No, they're
the same dynamic.
We just have two particles.
It's just like we
have one photon here,
another photon there.
It's the same thing.
And this is the same thing about
how string theory generates
gravity.
So let me just say
a few words here.
So at the beginning, when we
quantize the closed string,
we can see the closed
string moving, again,
in the rigid
Minkowski spacetime.
Yeah, because that
[INAUDIBLE] region.
We just consider in the
region in Minkowski spacetime.
But now, when you quantize
that closed string,
when you see that the closed
string actually half spin-2 two
excitations.
Half spin-2 excitations.
That means that string actually
has gravitational effect.
Unless you have spin-2
excitations, then
Einstein-- already
from Einstein,
gravity tells us that the
spacetime is no longer rigid,
that actually you can
deform the Minkowski
spacetime by putting
in those excitations,
these spin-2 excitations.
And if you put enough of
them, then [INAUDIBLE]
deform the Minkowski spacetime
to some other curve spacetime,
then you can actually
describe generically
the quantum
gravitational dynamics
of a general curved spacetime.
So here, it's the same thing.
We start with a
reach of the D-brane.
Then we quantize the
excitations-- then
we quantize the degrees
freedom on the D-brane.
And then we find that
those degrees freedom
corresponding to the
fluctuation of the D-brane.
And if you have
enough of them-- say
if you have phi only depend on
p to be the same everywhere,
so that's some coherent motion
for every point on this brane.
So then if you build enough
[INAUDIBLE] excitations,
then you can actually make
the D-brane move [INAUDIBLE]
become a fully dynamic object.
So that's precisely
the remarkable thing
about string theory.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: No, we don't know how
to describe a dynamical brane
from the beginning.
No, that's how we do it.
We first start
with some-- so this
is called a background
dependent quantization.
You start with a
specific solution.
specific configuration
of the D-brane, which you
happen to be able to quantize.
Then you can find
all the excitations
around that particular
configuration,
and then you can turn
on those excitations
to move away from those points.
So that's essentially
what we're doing here.
OK.
Let's stop.